many social animals like humans have  large brains and sophisticated cognition  is this true  for social carnivores like lions and  hyenas or are solitary meat-eaters like  leopards and tigers just as smart to get  the treat from this puzzle box the  hyenas didn't take long to figure out  they needed to pull the rope  Lions came in second some spent time  exploring the box which is also  indicative of having smarts this leopard  is also a busy Explorer and scores but  only six of the 11 leopards tested open  the box Tigers came and last only two of  these seven big cats like this one  opened the door the task doesn't require  being socially intelligent yet the group  living carnivores were better at it that  suggests that there's something about  being social that makes us smarter  overall